[Music]
hello everybody s my name is Pete all so
nice now though I was asked to give my
opinion on the game scum that we played
here on the iron Lords podcast I just
wanted to go over a couple of things
that I that I enjoyed the gameplay it's
kind of unique it's on the right rarer
side we really didn't get any direction
on what we were supposed to do kind of
like here's the game here's the controls
go ahead dive in and in the beginning
was very difficult to do it the the
learning curve on it was pretty pretty
big and I took a lot of time to figure
out the basic things on how to play and
I still had a still had some problems I
then ended up speaking to a friend of
mine who had played it and he showed me
a couple of ways to correctly play by
either going to get food from the
zombies or where to go to find certain
objects when I originally went in I was
looking around I couldn't find weapons I
couldn't find guns I couldn't find food
I couldn't find anything and then he
told me about this server that was
specifically made to just speed up the
spawn timer of all those items to double
speed essentially and it worked great
and I was I was having a blast with it
and an hour turned into three hours and
I was like oh my god I'm like this is
crazy and it was really really good the
gun mechanics it took me a little bit to
understand how they worked because it's
finding all these guns but I couldn't
load ammo into him and I was like what
is going on and then I realized after a
while of searching I ended up finding
the the clips and when I found those
clips you could end up taking the
bullets putting went to the clips and
then the clips you can put into the guns
kind of the same way that other games
have have played and then it started to
work out pretty well to be able to
defend myself but the there was such a
rarity of people
there were so many people playing there
was you know maxing out on all the
servers but I wasn't finding anybody the
world was so big and it felt okay
because it was more of a you know a
world survival type game but at the same
time I felt that I was all alone and I
was like wait a minute I want to I want
to find somebody I want to go hunt him I
want to get him kill him and I ended up
get finding one guy which you'll hear in
the clip but it was bugged I couldn't
even see him I all you saw was you know
I think a baseball bat and a rifle and
it was crazy so thankfully things
started working out pretty well and I
really started enjoying it and there was
a lot of a lot of little things that
account took me a little bit to get used
to but I started enjoying it more and
more and it's one of those survival
games very similar to what you would
expect from parkour but they take you to
an extreme more like how h1z1 was
supposed to be but these guys improved
it and did a lot better on it and I
thought it was good and when you died
you had the opportunity to respawn in a
certain area using the the points that
you you saved from your last character
or and you could pick where you wanted
to spawn or randomly respawn or things
like that and it worked out pretty well
hole in the fence so you know I thought
I thought the game was good and you know
if you have some time you wanted to burn
it access I would pick it up so it was
it was a lot of fun and so I would say
thank you all for a full interview and
the iron Lords podcast guys will be it
will be here on Sundays 11 o'clock
Eastern Standard Time and thank you all
for hanging out and you know check us
out and thank you very much
have a great have a great day everybody
right now do dom b's battle max
i if i knew i was going to do so much
boxing I would have picked up boxing
skill
like you serious right now
you know I think I'm gonna try to run
past the battle mech
oh my god there's another one down here
but there's a hangar I want to get into
dude open the door
over the door shut the door all right
we're in like okay
we got a gun
Oh 30 cows this is nuts
right vest
right vest tactical sweater
okay will be nice right now though if we
could get some meds
my health is decreasing a little by
little right now see that we please find
some medical supplies painkillers
something anything this is like the
mother lode of weaponry
all right man I'll send you a message
when the thing is all done
I am probably gonna die because I don't
have any medical supplies which I
figured was gonna happen so
why aren't you
server broken again is the server busted
oh I think it's broken
I think the service crashing
this service crash entail think we're
gonna be doomed can open the door
[Music]